[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardiña y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso oriente El magacín
quincenal de France 24 en el que les
acercamos las historias de medio oriente
América Latina en esta ocasión nos
traemos un programa especial dedicado al
análisis de las elecciones en Turquía
comenzamos
se hace con la presidencia de Turquía
revalidando su gobierno por otros cinco
años erdoan se impuso a su rival el
opositor de Centro izquierda que mal
kills darolu quien calificó los comicios
de injustos El islamista logró el
52,18% de los votos En esta segunda
vuelta electoral frente al 47,82 de
quilisarolu En esta segunda vuelta sin
precedentes casi 64 millones de turcos
estaban llamados a las urnas con una
participación de casi el 89%
. Perdón deberá hacer frente ahora a una
sociedad muy polarizada y a una fuerte
crisis económica el domingo muchos
partidarios salieron a las calles para
celebrar el triunfo del líder de la Cape
quien habló ante las masas con un
discurso de agradecimiento y arremetió
contra quillistarolo
como decíamos el partida el líder del
partido de la justicia y el desarrollo
el akp calificó la reelección como una
victoria electoral de los 85 millones de
habitantes de Turquía en su discurso
erdoan también acusó a la oposición de
estar aliada con el terrorismo kurdo y
de ser Pro lgbtiq más el líder con dos
décadas encargos políticos nueve de
ellos como presidente y 11 como Primer
Ministro obtuvo un sorpresivo apoyo en
muchas de las áreas de Turquía afectadas
por los trágicos terremotos del pasado
febrero que mataron a más de 50.000
personas Esto es lo que dijo erdoan en
su discurso de Victoria la noche del
domingo
como parte de la responsabilidad que nos
ha dado nuestra nación no estamos
enojados resentidos ni enfadados con
nadie ahora es el momento de dejar de
lado todos los debates y conflictos
relacionados con las elecciones y
unirnos en torno a nuestras metas y
sueños nacionales
la confianza y la estabilidad son las
cosas más importantes y continuaremos
con Estos principios construiremos una
economía sólida en torno a estas reglas
y una vez se conocieron los resultados
oficiales diversos líderes políticos
felicitaron a erdoan los primeros fueron
el Emir de Qatar o Víctor orbán el líder
húngaro más tarde llegaron los mensajes
del presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden el mandatario francés Emmanuel
macón o el presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin incluso su rival geopolítico el
presidente de Egipto abdel fatal Sisi
congratulo al líder Turco nuestro
periodista en Estambul Albert nayanos
cuenta más sobre la jornada electoral y
la reacciones al Triunfo de erdogan en
la región
receta y perdón revalida la presidencia
en Turquía con un 52% del apoyo popular
mientras que su contrincante del
opositor que malcharolo consiguió un 47%
de los votos alrededor de las 9 ya se
conocía la noticia de que erdogan
efectivamente había ganado esta segunda
vuelta de las elecciones el mismo salía
a la calle ante sus simpatizantes
realizaba un discurso en el barrio de
úscuda en Estambul no solamente cantaba
también se acordaba de la oposición se
acordaba del colectivo lgtb y acusaba
que maquillar arou de ser simpatizante
de la guerrilla de ser Aliado de la
guerrilla pkka este mismo también se
dirigía a sus simpatizantes que
malcelelulu decía que estas elecciones
habían sido las más injustas que él
podría haber imaginado y también decía
que hay que seguir defendiendo la
democracia las felicitaciones por parte
de otros líderes de la región No
tardaron en llegar los presidentes
tanto de Israel como de Palestina le
felicitaban tampoco faltó a la
felicitación y el jamaliet por parte de
azerbaiyán que recordemos es un socio
indispensable en la Turquía de erdogan
le seguían el Emir de Qatar y también
incluso los talibanes por parte de
Afganistán felicitaban a erdogan por
revalidar esta presidencia por tercera
vez
hagamos ahora un repaso histórico a
través de las más de dos décadas de
trabajos en cargos políticos de Rey
jettai perdón el hombre de 69 años el
islamista que construyó su carrera desde
un barrio obrero de Estambul hasta
convertirse en la figura autoritaria que
es hoy en día un controvertido
presidente con una amplia influencia que
aspira a colearse con el creador de la
Turquía moderna mustafá quemal atatürk
Este es un informe sobre su trayectoria
nació en un barrio obrero de Estambul
proyecta ibertoan hijo de una familia
migrante del mar Negro y dio una vida
sin lujos y llegó incluso a vender
comida en la calle pero una de sus
decisiones se le cambió la vida para
siempre su creencia islámica que le
llevó a afiliarse al partido de
salvación nacional islamista y lo
catapultó hasta la alcaldía de Estambul
en 1994 con una agenda Clara Apoyar el
islamismo en el país algo que le costó
una condena de 10 meses de prisión fue
declarado culpable solo por leer un
poema y me gustaría acusar que esto es
una tragedia y una vergüenza para
nuestra historia jurídica
[Aplausos]
tras cuatro meses en la cárcel y la
prohibición de su partido decidió
alejarse del ala más dura del islam y
fundar un partido más moderado el ácape
con él ganó las elecciones generales de
2002 y consiguió convertirse en el
primer jefe de gobierno islamista de
Turquía en 2003
dado que la mayoría de la población
turca es musulmana el éxito Turco en el
proceso de la Unión Europea será un gran
ejemplo para otros países musulmanes y
mostrará como la democracia puede
convivir muy bien con el islam
con el inicio llegó el crecimiento
económico y la modernización del país
pero también los altibajos y polémicas
en torno a su figura los críticos lo
acusaban de ser cada vez más autoritario
y De no respetar los Derechos Humanos
no se puede tratar a las mujeres y a los
hombres igual porque su naturaleza Es
diferente
tras acotar sus mandatos como Primer
Ministro erdogan se convirtió en
presidente en 2014 de nuevo con una gran
promesa una nueva constitución y situar
a Turquía entre las diez economías del
mundo no obstante en julio de 2016 un
intento de golpe de estado que se saldó
con casi 300 muertos hizo tambalear su
gobierno Y aunque en 2017 ganó un
referendo que le otorgaba más poderes su
base electoral ha cambiado en los
últimos años
por su parte el opositor de la alianza
de Centro izquierda que mal
quilícedarolu quien por primera vez en
la historia moderna de Turquía llevó a
Joanna una segunda vuelta finalmente no
pudo obtener la mayoría de los votos
necesarios para asegurar su Victoria la
oposición no declaró irregularidades la
noche electoral pero que les darólulu
calificó La derrota de injusta la
coalición opositora se hizo sin embargo
con las grandes ciudades de Turquía
Estambul y la capital ankara Esto es lo
que dijo el veterano opositor
experimentamos la elección más injusta
de los últimos años se movilizaron todos
los medios del Estado para un partido
político todas las posibilidades se
pusieron bajo los pies de un hombre en
esta elección surgió la voluntad del
pueblo de cambiar un régimen autoritario
a pesar de las presiones continuaremos
nuestra lucha en todos los frentes
analicemos ahora los retos a los que
debe hacer frente
los próximos cinco años de mandato tanto
en materia internacional como dentro de
su país y para ello Contamos con Enrique
repollo acedo analista especialista en
geopolítica y conflictos Gracias por
estar en France 24 Enrique lo primero
que quería preguntarte es la primera vez
que Turquía va a segunda vuelta
electoral erdoan nunca estuvo tan cerca
de perder y sin embargo la población
turca Sigue confiando en él A qué se
debe esto
Muchas gracias por la invitación un gran
saludo a toda la audiencia y desde luego
lo que se debe es a la cuestión
económica interna la bueno la pérdida de
valor de la lira la inflación constante
en los últimos años y que eso
evidentemente es algo que afecta a toda
la población que por supuesto se puede
contraponer a una hábil política
exterior que es el gran punto fuerte de
erdogan mostrar como decía ayer erdogan
en su discurso En definitiva es Turquía
es un país único es un país Turco y
musulmán
gran potencia en el mundo
influyente etcétera Y entonces ese ha
sido su gran punto de contrapeso frente
a la cuestión interna que es por
supuesto la inflación que afecta a toda
la población pero bueno a cambio de eso
tienen un estado un país más fuerte un
país más influyente en el mundo y bueno
desde luego ahí ha estado la elección
tan reñida en esta ocasión y por eso ha
acabado en una segunda vuelta Porque si
bien ha tenido un buen desempeño a nivel
externo claro la cuestión falló ahí en
la en la parte interna y por el lado del
terremoto Pues bueno algunos dicen que
sí le afectó mucho otros que no En
definitiva una cuestión es un terremoto
un desastre natural que no se puede
prever que simplemente sucede no es como
casos de Huracanes donde sí se puede
prever su trayectoria y por tanto
proceder a la evacuación de la gente
además Bueno también en la cuestión del
terremoto
polémicas centros sobre todo en
diferentes empresas constructoras y la
mala calidad de sus obras que llevó
directamente al derrumbe como
azucarillos de grandes edificios y de
ahí la enorme cantidad de víctimas
mortales en terremoto también quería
preguntarte en materia internacional
sobre todo en su relación con occidente
Cuáles son los desafíos que se vienen
ahora por delante para erdoan en un
contexto de guerra en Ucrania siendo
también el Aliado díscolo de la otan
como cree también que acoge Estados
Unidos o la Unión Europea a esta
reelección
pues desde luego no les ha gustado a
occidente porque no deja de ser el
candidato que lleva ese rumbo propio
esa agenda propia Más allá de lo que
pueda
influirle la Unión Europea o ordenarle
la otan o guiarle a través de la otra En
definitiva Turquía con erdogan había
mostrado ser un jugador propio dentro de
dentro del tablero internacional
especialmente en el Mediterráneo mar
Negro cáucaso y Oriente medio que es
donde tiene sus raíces y sus miras
geopolíticas más directas Turquía y que
siempre además ha buscado ser aunque
todos le odien por algo también todos le
necesitan por algo y esa ha sido la
clave internacional de erdogan que si
bien cada uno le pueda odiar por algún
motivo todos le acaban necesitando para
algo y entonces pues vale más la
necesidad que el odio y por eso pues por
ejemplo con erdogan ha buscado
convertirse en que si el petróleo ruso
no entra por Europa pues entrará por
Turquía también el gas que pueda venir
de Qatar u otros recursos naturales
desde Irak y Siria que todo también pase
por vía terrestre a través de Turquía y
así convertir digamos a Turquía en el
Sublime Grifo si en el periodo anterior
en el periodo Imperial se les llamaba la
Sublime puerta ahora sería el Sublime
Grifo y que la Unión Europea dependiera
de que erdogan pudiera bloquear ese
Grifo intermedio de paso y también por
supuesto beneficiarse de esos de ese
tránsito gasístico y petrolífero a
través de su propio territorio y ese
bueno es uno de los muchos ejemplos que
se puede ver otro es su participación
por ejemplo en la negociación del Gran
en el acuerdo del grano con Rusia y
Ucrania otra serie de acuerdos en
Oriente medio también lo hemos en Siria
con la reunión a cuatro bandas entre
Turquía Siria Irán y Rusia es decir un
erdogan orientándose precisamente hacia
Oriente hacia el espacio asiático
dejando al margen al espacio europeo
también por razones evidentes Turquía
lleva desde 1999 esperando
ya
Enrique Muchísimas gracias Nos quedamos
sin tiempo pero muchas gracias por este
análisis y por habernos acompañado en
France 24
gracias a ustedes hasta la próxima
llegamos así al final de esta edición
especial de Expreso Oriente Muchas
gracias por acompañarnos y sigan con más
información en nuestra página web France
24.com
[Música]